So today Vivia we'll be talking about
the German ideology and Mark's becoming a
historical materialist.
Um,
I just wanted to make a couple of more
comments about the thesis on the fire of
our marks is on the edge moving away
from naturalism or to historical
materialism or, um, but uh,
the emphasis and the thesis on
fiber is not so much on materialism,
but it is much more on a praxis.
Uh,
action change.
The lack of determination marks as
I materialist is usually seen as a
determinist.
And if you took other courses where
march was, march was stashed upon,
you were probably told marks
is a determinist economic
determinist and there's a
lot of to it,
but half truths and he's
struggling in the dcis on fire.
But, um, as I said,
he's on his way from
naturalism to materialism.
And the central idea is, as I said, Baxis
human practices.
And that's why I put down on the slides
that it is a kind of dialectical about
Mark's represents in the thesis on fire
back now might seem self very rarely
used the term dialectic. God. Uh,
he had a clear enough mind to be
suspicious about the word dialectics,
a valance at an old age.
He wrote a letter to angles and he said,
uh, you know, Frederick,
what that I don't know what something.
Then I say it is dialectical,
right?
So the I on insulin,
you couldn't really find out what the
relationship between two phenomena is.
Then you say, well this is the car. Well,
it's a bit too simplistic.
Don't derm dialectical as
I am sure you all know, go,
go back to Greek philosophy.
But even in Greek philosophy,
the idea of dialectics was
emphasizing change and the process,
a theme as Greek philosopher once said,
and that jazz to capture
the essence of dialectics,
you cannot in the same river twice because
if you step in the river five minutes
later, that is not quite the same
liver because the water is gone.
This is a different water,
right?
So the dialectics means that the
word is in flux is in change.
That's I think one important idea.
Dialectics.
And in the thesis on Feuerbach,
Marx emphasizes right that we are changing
the world now they're just taking it
right in this sense he is dialectical
and this is why he still has this
materialism.
And the tournament is there is another,
um, uh, um,
more contemporary adaptation
of the word dialectics,
which comes from Garel Kagel.
And Mark's again was shying
away to use it very often,
but his friend Frederick Engels use it.
He even said that it's a
dialectical materialism and me,
the distinction between historical
and dialectical materialism.
Now,
what was dialectics in Hagar?
He got us trying to capturing
the process of change right?
Already in Greek philosophy,
the dialect auditions emphasized
that if you are looking at the verb,
this is not a picture,
it is a movie, right?
And every minute you
see something different,
now he go try to come to terms with what
is the essence of this change and this
essence of these change.
He was looking at contradictions,
contradictions,
drive the change.
So he got made a big
distinction between these,
these entities is and synthesis.
So the change,
what dialectics captures
normally in social life,
it starts with the thesis,
right?
An actual conditions and entities is
which is the negation of their situation
and then it leads to a synthesis,
which is the negation of the negation,
right?
In some ways the original condition is
reconstituted but in a different way as
Hagar put it,
reserving good by abolishing yet right.
That's the he'd Guardian
inside what actually was a,
this kind of logic was a
attractive to marks and a Marxist.
Anyways, so this is dialectical
and marks from dialectical,
from the philosophy of practices where
praxis is the crucial eventually move
stove arts and more clearly
the terministic positivistic
social science in which
you have a very clear idea
of what is the key because,
and the concept Vance's right.
Uh,
doing very much but positive is social
science is doing today identifying the
dependent variable and independent
variable to come up with a hypotheses,
how the dependent variable veal cause
variation in the independent variable of
your cost variation in the dependent
variable and then to describe it,
that is very much the mature marks.
And because march was
moving into, uh, today,
Viveo call it normal science,
he becomes a real scientist.
Evolves is becoming so much of a
scientist that that volume point,
he began to a doubt that is much sense
to make a distinction between social
sciences and sciences.
He himself began to see himself
as the Darvin of social sciences.
You've are so much attracted
with scientific reasoning,
delete marks the second mark.
So maybe we'll start talking about that.
He actually fought a vile consider to
dedicate the book capital to Charles
Darvey because he saw himself
as doing for human history.
But Mark's did to the
evolution of the species.
He wanted to do an evolution
of human societies.
Now, luckily for Marx, he
did not do that, right?
He did not become a social Darwinist.
Right.
He resisted that temptation,
but he was stemmed it.
Okay. I just want to go
back very briefly to, uh,
to thesis on fire bath because
they are very important,
right? And this is the idea, right?
He is now criticizing cried Feuerbach.
And the problem with fire back,
he said that foyer Feuerbach and other
people who've are materialists before
him,
right?
They thought that there are the
things outside their objective decks,
the are outside of the subject.
This creates and knowledge
about these object.
He crawled that Gig and stomped object
and the knowledge is nothing else but a
reflection in human mind of the object
outside that this is a very typical
theory of truth, right? Uh,
very vitally share today and
probably our theory of tools,
but many of you in this room share
right then is your knowledge accurate?
You think about your mind as a mirror.
If the image of the object or the
objective world outside is accurately
reflected in the mirror of your mind,
then you got it right.
So what we try to do is to have the most
perfect mirror in our mind and capture
the objective reality as precisely
as much in detail as possible.
Well,
mark says,
this is simply a ref,
uh,
you know,
reflection and this should go beyond that,
right?
He said,
what is good about what Feuerbach
dead or what is good about a phone,
for instance,
what Hmong desk cured did.
These were the two people we
discussed so far over clearly,
you know,
um,
material it slammed me and hops was
pretty much and materialist as well,
right? Believing that this is
sort of biological conditions,
did you dive us and makes us what we are?
So they all start the
throne sensuousness right?
That the,
the reality is something what we
can get that through our senses,
right?
We smelly it to be touchy to see it.
And unless we touched it,
we see it, we smell it,
we doubt read that it exists. Right?
There's the difference, right?
Between materialists and idealist ideas.
You don't get through
your senses, right? Uh,
you get it through your
mind, but he said, this is,
these materialism is censures only
in the sense of contemplation.
The object is outside of the subject
and you get a grasp of it through your
senses. And he said, well,
but what I am suggesting in
my new approach is sensors or,
right,
but a census,
human activity and activity as such.
I mentioned very briefly
that this last lecture,
let me just may come
back to this point again.
This is what you're going
to harbor mass. Um, the, uh,
arguably the greatest philosopher
of the 20th century. Well,
he's still alive, but you may, you know,
the 21st century has a long
way to go to the side. Oh,
the will be the greatest philosopher,
but many things that you're going to,
harbor mass was the greatest
philosopher of the 20th century.
He said, well, yes, uh, uh,
mice in the thesis on fire Bar
is right hip. At one point.
I mean,
hubber must had his culture turn
moved away from materialism,
but in most of his life,
he said,
I am a material list because I also
believe that the ultimate reality has to
come through sensors,
experiences through the
senses. Right? But he said,
Mark's literature on the mature marks
became reductionist because the sensors
activity, he identified
the, the economy, right?
We production the economic activities.
And he said in the thesis on fire,
but he got it right.
Oh,
sensors activity our material.
So therefore he says,
let us not simply limit
our analysis to production,
but let's look at human interaction
then the interact with each other.
And this is also as sensors activity,
right?
So he creates peace between
Zygmunt Fried and Karl Marx.
Many people try to do that right now.
This is not an opposition that it is
either production or your sexual drives.
You know,
you're a sexual drives.
Your sexual interaction with
others is very much sensors.
Right?
It's actually more
sensors than doing a job.
Right. Then, you know,
being in a Mac Donald's
and serving hamburgers,
that sensors activity,
but or, right. You know,
sexually introduction
is very much sensors.
That's a harbor must point and
marks in the thesis on fire,
but opens this book possibility up.
It's a very open argument. Okay. Uh,
this is actually one of the
reasons why he does not publish it.
It's still vague.
He wanted to be more precise.
And then he wanted to go,
he was reading Adam Smith and Ricardo
and spent all of his time in the British
library, these economists and
she volunteers to be bang,
bring it back down to earth to echo
the economy and economic interest.
And now let me start to this because
I think that's very important.
The theory of truths.
And I want you to think about it.
I think this is very interesting.
So what is true
and to be very simplistic,
right?
You have two competing theories of truths.
One theory of choose,
but I think most of you have in your
mind is the kind of reflection theory of
truths that our mind is
a mirror more accurately.
It reflects the objective
reality out there. Uh,
more chew the knowledge.
What we have in our mind is,
um, marks in the thesis
on fire bar says not. So
the choose is a practical question.
The problem with the reflection theory
of choose is that it is positive list and
it is.
Eliana did I throw in another word coined
by a major Marxist philosopher of the
20th century gorilla glue couch.
He guarded.
This is re fied consciousness re fied.
You know,
Lucas was writing in German and in German
he used the term fair Dingley Hoang
they ink means to thing. I think
ratification is a very good translation.
Only those of us who speak English about
Dumas speak Latin don't necessarily
require get it right.
[inaudible] in Latin means the think ray
fication is the process in which return
stuff, but she's what is not
a thing into an objective.
Think it's a kind of fright look Kashian
reinterpretation of Mark's notion of
alienation.
Mark Stern,
right in German for a vacation
was and three [inaudible] framed.
That means, uh, alien, right?
So alienation is a good translation,
right?
You are alienated if you feel alien,
if you'll feel homeless in this world.
Now I think,
but look, uh, look, arch has
an interesting idea, right?
That the essence of alienation is
when we're beginning to see the world.
But actually we created the work.
It worked, this out creation.
I this as this objective world via rules.
We do not see ourself as
the masters of the world,
but we see ourselves as
ruled by the verdict,
right?
And this is the ray five consciousness.
When we beginning to see
the objective reality,
we cannot do anything about it,
right?
And the essence is the
philosophy of practices of
the young Marx ending with the
thesis on fire.
But the point is to change it.
The point is to change the world. So, uh,
in contemporary, uh, this course,
we usually call this positivism,
right?
Positivists are those social scientists
who think that our objective facts out
of there and the purpose of social
investigation is to establish the most
objectively and most concretely what
those objective social facts are.
You are an economist. You describe
the objective facts, right?
You say,
Val,
you have to maximize profit because
if you do not maximize profit,
then you will be vived out of business,
right?
This is almost like the force of nature.
Again, if I can recall, uh, uh,
yarrow glow catch,
he coined these wonderful term,
second nature,
right?
That's the beginning to think about
social life as if it were natural,
as if it would have the power of nature.
The economic laws look like lightening,
you know, like, you know,
this forced really like earth scrapes you.
We can't do virtually
nothing about earthquake. I,
if we can predict what we can't predict,
we just can't get into our
car and get out of it, right?
But even we cannot really
predict earthquakes. That's
one of the problems, right?
Well, now we can predict when a
hurricane is coming, what can we do?
You get in the car and get out of there
where the hurricane and we are calm now,
you know, uh, the point
is that positive is,
does posts,
it's social phenomena as if
they had the force of nature.
And that's what [inaudible] called
the coronate, the social of word,
as if it were second nature.
As if had the force of nature.
They said, this is all wrong
because this is the road.
What we created this should
the rule it all right?
That's the idea to overcome Aliya nation
to become the master of your fate,
right? To be able, right,
to change the objective conditions.
And you know,
in the German ideology marks puts
it very, very powerful. It's,
I will say it is almost the last word,
but in this debate he sat bosses sad.
I don't think anybody really
improved on it. He said, well,
humans change their conditions,
but we were born under certain certain
conditions and we can only change the
conditions we were born into.
Right?
So it's an interesting
interaction between, yes,
I mean the county to do anything,
right,
because we were born into conditions,
but we seen some limits.
We can change those
conditions by the vase,
not all that different from hops,
right?
And voluntary action.
The theory of voluntary action.
There is a similarity here.
Now I finish this and get on to the,
uh, German ideology that that is
one thing, but I cannot leave out,
uh,
I think too insightful and
important to leave it out.
So let me come back to the
subject and object shoe, right?
What I've suggested.
It is so extremely important,
not only for marks but for the whole
critical theory and the in fact a four NT
positivism of all sorts in
the 20th and 21st century.
Uh, I mentioned for
instance, cultural theory,
which is very strongly anti positivist,
right and rejects social
science as normal science.
So what we have is right, uh, subject
and that is you, right? The,
the person who has a consciousness and
okay
is a cognitive south.
A subject is involved
in cognitive activity,
creating knowledge and then that are
objects about which be create a march,
uh,
ref lecture on theory of,
to sad that this is a mirror and
if the objects are accurately,
um, uh, um,
described in the mirror of our mind,
that is true.
This is the whole test of having
verification of hypotheses,
right?
I develop a hypotheses,
then I go there and test it on the
social reality and if it is matches,
then it is verified.
I got through right now
the philosophy of breath.
She says the tools is not
simply a reflection is an
introduction between subject
and object.
That's about through cities.
And that is this a
wonderful,
a few Lasha for not that easy to read.
Uh,
but still I think Vonda flew mind.
His name is Adora.
No,
I don't know.
Belonged to the Frankfurt school and was
active mainly in the 1940s and sixties
there.
Theism sixties and Bella,
he formulated the soul power fully.
[inaudible] sad what is true.
He said,
the truth is the force field between
subject and object are not simply a
reflection of the object,
but it is between the tension
of subject and object. Right?
I think this is beautiful.
The darn right.
It is in the force field
of subject and object.
Uh, so, uh,
let me also add one more point
and then we can move away, uh,
the theory of truth.
But I want you guys to
think about what East Jews,
right? Ben, can you say an idea is true?
In fact, Adorno at one
point says about Nazis, man,
you know, he, he said experiencing,
he was Jewish.
Shan's Manny off his family,
killed right by the Nazis.
And he said,
the reality [inaudible] reality is so
measurable that it does not deserve to be
called true.
You see the point,
you also say that occasionally when you
say something horrible and you can say
no, that cannot be true, right?
This is exactly our door.
Most point,
these can be so miserable that
you say it cannot be true.
And the idea is that the
are sure miserable that you
are completely bow or less
nervous about this nature like forces do.
It is unacceptable,
right? You should be able to
do something about it, right?
They should have been able to do something
about Auschwitz and they could not do
anything about it. And
that's what our door, no sad.
These are reality was such that
it should not be called true.
It cannot be throughs.
You see what it is getting a very final
point about this theory of truth and
this is through another guy,
Karl Mannheim.
Okay.
This is very much along these line.
He was very much not a Marxist.
It was a conservative philosopher.
Uh,
his major work was done in England.
Um,
and Manheim once said,
the truth is not being
the truth is becoming
Bingo.
Right?
Wonderful reports,
right?
The juice is not simply that
you describe how things are,
you really know about.
The truth is when you know what it
can be and what you can do about it,
the real purpose of cognition is,
is not simply to describe the
word, but to change it, right?
To make it a better world.
That's when you have real truths,
when you know how to make
the world better, right?
So the truth is not being but becoming.
And that's the philosophy of practices.
But I think that's where
Mark's is, um, in, uh, uh, uh,
writing that these are some fire buff
and that's what he is moving away from
when he,
uh,
beginning carite the German ideology,
what is he writing together,
which read Frederick Engels, uh,
and now you see he has to abandon,
he,
he cannot publish the book,
the thesis on fire because it
is too voluntaristic. Right?
He abandoned the Paris
manuscript because it was fluffy,
right?
Nobody would believe me
that the revolution Viacom
because the proletariat is
alienated. And then when
he finished, I think this,
I mean,
not all 11 sentences are great,
but some of those sentences
are really great sentences.
He wrote it down and he never
published it because he said, well,
this is still voluntary stick,
right?
I have to come up with a more curative,
which we approved the Paul that the
level of [inaudible] meal come capitalism
has to fall.
It is not only a question whether we
decide to change it or we don't have to
change it,
right?
I have to come up with a theory which
we approve that capitalism will have to
fall,
right?
That's what puts him into
the deterministic mode.
He actually never becomes real
in deterministic. It's uh, uh,
a very simplistic reading of Marx.
You know,
after all this guy is a
theorist of the revolution,
he sold that revolutionary idea
should be put into people's head.
Hit this idea.
I did not think that ideas do not matter
if he would have believe ideas do not
match her. He will not have spent, you
know, all of his Sam eight in the morning,
nine until 9:00 PM in the British library.
And writing books,
right? If ideas do not match her, if I do,
you write down ideas because he believed
that ideas for change the world,
right? So he was never
completely a deterministic.
But in the nature of divert,
he's moving Dover's economic determinism.
And the reason is that now he
wants to blue that capitalism.
Yes,
it had great achievement.
If during the time of capitalism
society developed more than ever before,
uh, capitalism, but nevertheless
it, you'll have to come an end.
Capitalism, they are not last forever
and now he has to prove that these,
that it must come to an end.
So that puts him on a
deterministic trajectory.
That's what makes him,
he has to become,
he has to accept materialism,
that material conditions,
that term mine,
human action and consciousness.
So that's what he does. He,
they are beginning to develop
in the German ideology.
And this is the structure of the book.
The first ship that is a critique on fire.
Uh,
Dave's on from the thesis on fire back,
but by tens the argument and becomes
strictly materialist and gets out of these
voluntary stick element.
He has some introductory remarks,
him about critique of idealism and the
premises of the new materialism he is
proposing now,
but he's beginning to call him now.
He's StoryCorps materialism stays away
from the word dialectic the car and then
he develops thrive and material.
His conception of history and
historical development. Uh,
he replaces Adam Smith's
categorization of societies as hunting,
gathering, um, uh,
grazing agriculture or commercial.
But I knew type ology these new type
Ology of you will be the type Ology of the
modes of production.
Uh,
not in fact in the ideology.
He stays pretty close to Adam
Smith's cyber. Your point, the south,
and this is one of his problems.
This is one of the reasons by the German
ideology was also left unfinished and
unpublished.
Right as I,
as I indicated it was first
published and not the complete text,
only in 1903,
well after the death of Marx and Engels,
then he was right.
It's about the origins of idealists,
conception of history. There it
is coming from, uh, he's rights,
thinking about the development of
productive forces and eventually,
uh, this covers the notion
of relations of production.
I've you make a big deal
out of this because I,
I think that's one of the reasons that
the German ideology fails that until the
very end.
He does not know the term of
relations of production and he,
uh,
he runs into some very big problems and
then he dies on lunar bower and Mexico
in there.
These are young here.
Galleons people usually don't read
these chapters and volume two,
I mean, you must be a Marx Marx
expert to read this. This is reality.
Basically irrelevant. Not
Very interesting. Okay.
What are the major themes
in the German ideology?
First he offers a
materialist view of history.
Then he offers a theory
of modes of production.
Then he beginning to develop
forces of production.
Um, and initially division of
Labor. And this is a problem.
This is very much Adam Smith.
She's still very strongly on under Adam
Smith and understands the evolution of
society as the evolution of division
of Labor. And then he describes,
uh,
ties to describe the forces of
production and division of Labor,
uh,
more so production and describes subsect
fan most of production and give her
view about how human history and
then he develops. But I would call,
he's the first who creates
a sociology Maraloge,
how to study sociological.
He's socially how you can understand
conscience who human consciousness.
Okay.
So the materials view of history.
And now here you can see
marks the positivist social
scientists speaking and in
mice is the first of positive is
social scientist rigorous positive is
scientists.
And what he's describes here
will be subscribed and accepted.
Most of the positive is stipes in
your political science or sociology or
economics or psychology departments,
right?
This at the premises from which we begin
with are not arbitrary once now dogmas
about real Ramesses from
which abstractions can only
be made in the imagination.
So you start from the objective conditions
and then you speculate from this.
So what we start our,
our real individuals and the activities
of these individual actual activities of
these individuals. Um, and
then he moves what most,
a little Ford,
their,
their conditions of life both
for the find already existing.
And those were the produce
by that activities, right?
So he said, German philosophers
there send it from uh, uh,
uh, uh, uh, the heaven to earth.
Now the artists sending from
Earth to have her right,
you do not deduction.
We do induction.
This is the inductive method.
What we use.
And if you add a positivist,
Uva, love it. You see,
this is real serious science,
right? Looking at facts.
And then he said, well,
ideas have no history,
no development man developing the
material conditions and their material
intercourse, uh, uh,
altered their thinking.
So it is really our material existence,
which has a history and
ideas reflect doors,
material conditions.
Then then he beginnings to develop the
theory of most of production. He said,
well man can distinguish from
animals in different ways.
But most important is that we produce
that we change the environment in a
purposeful manner, right?
That he had an image,
how to change the physical environment
for us and what lecturey actually
mattress is not simply what we produce.
And this is a very important idea,
but the mood of production,
how the produce,
how the Yankee gauge each other.
Because this will change in history since
not simply what we produce. You know,
this is a revolutionary idea.
Again, this is completely new.
In March,
before Numarx you went into a museum
and the museum was about great people,
right?
These were kings and Queens
and genitals and boobs,
whose pictures for presented that,
and this is the way how
history was described.
Now you go into a historian,
now you can see this is the living room,
how people lived in a Roman times,
and this is the way how they ate.
This is the way how they cooked.
And these are the instrument by
which they produce the stuff,
what they cooked in the kitchen.
All right,
this is how a modern
historical museum look slide.
And this comes,
this is really a revolution from March.
History is not the history of great ideas
and great man or great the men history
is the idea of the actual they,
how people lived and produced
and reproduced their, uh,
ideas. Now he said, well,
we can distinguish therefore
a differences between nature,
how the productive forces and he means
by technology is developing and how he
uses initially the term the Inter
intercourse internal interest course is
changing. And by this here, the
first two division of labor,
that is Smithian idea of
Adam Smith's idea, right?
That history of wolves,
of greater division of Labor.
They will see in Emil Durkheim
also the central idea.
You can see the evolution of society
by increasing division of Labor.
Um,
and then he cries to come up with
subsequent he molds of production.
Now he said,
now I actually can discard the history
as different types of mood of protocol
production. Uh, moving
from elementary forms.
So most elementary form is tribal society
in tribal society that the technology
is very simple and that is
very little division of labor.
He is sexist enough to say there is a
natural division of labor between man and
a man.
Man,
go hunting and women go collecting
goods in the forest and that he calls
natural. This is of course a
sexist proposition. Loud, you know,
he was writing, it's,
you know, in 1845, uh,
was not the only man who was sexist.
Now the second four ms, he said,
ancient communal or state proper,
the antiquity.
Now you have development of forces
of production and in fact you have a
separation of ownership and greater
division of Labor that now people can
produce more than necessarily
for their survival.
Therefore there will be slaves who were
working day and night and there there'll
be philosophers who sit in Athens
and Rome and have great ideas,
right?
They caused the slaves producer stuff,
what they can eat and they can enjoy.
So the division of Labor
evolves and then the cure.
Now we have the evolution of
few dollars. Well, slaves,
you're a great producing,
cheap bog.
The problem with sleeves that they did
not have Nazi Shin Incentive to use a
very complicated technology.
You had to supervise them very closely
because they really hated your guts.
And if they could, they didn't break
right? The instruments, if they could.
So he will did not want to give them
complex technologies. Saw you invent,
served on, you say, you know,
why don't you become a
surf rather than a slave.
You can have your house and I give
you a piece of land and if you behave
yourself two days, you were
on my ass stage. Right?
And you produce stuff for me and I
let you to spend the rest of the week
producing for yourself.
But the big problem is that
the evolution of few dollars,
the fall of Rome and Greece,
um, and uh, you know,
rise of Sharla mine. Yeah. And you
know, the dark and Middle Ages,
the division of labor,
the not have a law that was last
division of Labor in the 11th century,
12th century than it was in
the first and second century.
So the methodology breaks down.
She was in deep trouble and as
you can see, you can either text,
he leaves after this,
the page blank, he said,
I'm in trouble, right? I have
to start this all over again.
And he starts all over
again and tries to come off.
It's something better now.
Sociology of knowledge,
very important contribution.
This is on the fortunately
completely wrong. What you say,
but the methodology is extremely important
and informed people who were studying
cognition and knowledge ever since.
And he makes these very
important a suggestion.
They'll life that termites consciousness
rather than the other way around.
And the other argument, which I
think is desperately wrong, uh,
but very insightful ruling
class, uh, all of us,
uh,
debtor,
your ruling guardians of each epoch now
live debtor minds consciousness and this
is a kind of the essence
right of materialism, right?
Definite individuals who are productive,
reactive in definite way,
m curled into definite social
and political relationships.
The production of ideas is the first
directly interwoven with material activity
and the material intercourse of men.
Dare me.
You know how much money you have in
your pocket and Ivy are telling you what
your ideas are to put it very
simplistic right there on me,
which class you belong to and ivy,
we'll be able to tell you,
you write what your ideas are right now.
Indeed,
we know that is a strong class component.
For instance,
in voting behavior,
not so much in the United States
because in the United States,
if you are poor, you
usually do not. Whoa. Right?
And therefore,
you know,
the Democratic Party's kind of scrambling
to get a little working class road or
a restyle scaring,
right?
The middleclass of a for voting them
as a big traditional trouble of the
Democratic Party. But if you look
at Europe or you look at Australia,
the Australian Labor Party was
getting righteous shortage,
you know, very keen classroom.
So tell me, you were what right.
He will cast position is,
and either you're Kelly,
you how you reward in the next elections.
As I said in the U s doesn't work,
but it doesn't work in Sweden.
He did work in England for a long time.
It by enlarge worked in
Australia. Right? If you are,
to some extent even works in the United
States where there are some very rich
people who are Democrats,
but typically those guys
who are very rich, don't,
they tend to be Republican, right?
I think they probably do. All right.
So, I mean that, yeah, this is what Mars
is like Yeti. And yeah, try to tell me,
you know,
what your material interests are.
And then I tell you what is on your mind.
The reductionist, again,
Vivio read Zigman Fried.
He said, well, true, but this
is not only economic interests.
There are me,
the history of your sex life.
And I tell you what is
on your mind, right? Uh,
you know, it's analogous
argument, right? It is existence,
which determines consciousness,
right? Most of them said, well,
it's not necessarily true that
what you is in your mind. True.
But I know that it is coming from right.
You are,
you've earned in Lovick your
mother, right? And we have,
if you were a man and your soup
last or your desire for your mother,
and that's where you have, you are
these false ideas in your mind, right?
Well, you look good. You have a shy
girl and he would allow him factor.
You could not food field these lava.
So press your desire and you have all
these strange ideas that that's why you
are neurotic. Right? And
I can tell you right.
That's the way how it Marcel
are you, it sort of, you know,
this is also reduction in spite of it,
but that is a common interesting idea.
We'll VR biologically class wise,
race wise,
gender vice.
What makes a difference?
I see in the discussion
sections very often, right?
If you have a real hot
topic, you know, uh,
do you want to have universal
how scared for instance,
that is usually agenda division in
the class, right? Uh, so you know,
gender has an impact,
right? Not speaking about,
through to affirmative action,
right? Well, of course,
Vr in a liberal university,
few people dare to speak up
against affirmative action,
but you know, I'm all
may have EITs, males,
well that is usually less
articulation, right? To the fan,
the idea of affirmative action.
The men and minorities are more
likely to the family. Okay. So I,
I know who you are. I don't know
what your ideas, we'll be right.
Your interest for your ideas.
That's the idea.
I think this is a very important idea,
right?
Put in a simplistic way.
And that comes to the idea that
the ruling class, um, uh, is, uh,
really producing the ruling ideas bell.
Not quite true,
but that is an element of truth street,
right?
There is an ideological hegemony and,
okay.
Um,
that's about it for today.
Thank you.